James Winson the squeeze is on the limit
Liberal Democrat vote you've gone from
23% at the beginning of October in the
polls to 15% what's going wrong well I
mean we've certainly seen a stitch-up
deal between Boris Johnson and Nigel
Farage that certainly made things more
challenging but out of it the polls
stand the path to stopping Boris Johnson
becoming Prime Minister relies even more
on the Liberal Democrats because we are
the party that can take significant
numbers of seats from Boris Johnson and
his Conservatives no one seriously
thinks that Labour are going to make an
inroads against the Conservatives but
the Liberal Democrats can and the
Conservatives are worried about that
okay let's pick up on Nigel Farage
because last week he announced that he
wasn't going to stand against the
Conservatives and conservative held
seats because he wants brexit above all
outs and he didn't want to split the
conservative vote I mean look the
reality of this is you're you're not
going to be Prime Minister and what's
worse you risk splitting the vote you're
going to become the handmaiden of Boris
Johnson's brexit because you're gonna
split the remain vote not at all as I
say if we want to stop Boris Johnson and
his bad brexit deal he's stitch up with
Nigel Faraj he needs to lose MPs at this
election and it's the Liberal Democrats
who can win mp's from Boris Johnson and
that's why our role in this is so
crucial and why people who want to
remain who want to stop breaks it and
stop Boris Johnson need to vote Liberal
Democrat this time okay I'm gonna stick
on this and we're going to some other
stuff later but just in terms of you
taking seats of Boris Johnson your your
manifesto is predicated on remaining in
the EU has been the most important thing
of it trumps everything party interest
it's in the national interest isn't it
the best thing then to vote labour and
get a second referendum I mean I
disagree I think time and again the
Labour Party have let down
millions of people in this country who
want to remain the liberal having a
second referendum the Liberal Democrats
have been leading that campaign for a
people's vote 17 times we tabled
amendments in Parliament to try to
secure one the most recently was just a
few weeks ago if I may respond with
feature ellipsis or we may well have
been in our peoples won't referendum
right no but I know a second referendum
and the likely outcome of this election
is either a Boris Johnson in number 10
or a Labour minority government or
Jeremy Corbyn in number 10 and if you
take votes from labour and let the
Tories through the middle you'll split
in the vote and you become the
handmaiden of brexit I think that's a
real risk for you Joe Spencer I
fundamentally disagree first of all
because labour or not apartheid remain
and and second of all because but we can
win to the second referendum but we can
but we can win seats from Boris Johnson
and labour can't and that's why it's so
important but in some but okay let's
take a seat let's take Canterbury right
the remain vote in Canterbury if you
stand in counter groups you're going to
do it's likely that the Tories will take
that seat back off labour
let's take Putney if you can test that
is a straight labour conservative
marginal you go in you take a few
thousand votes that seat stays Tory I
mean you're splitting I mean this is a
serious issue why don't you just stand
down and save a seat because you know
we're we're a party that is standing for
liberal values for a fair open inclusive
society and internationalist perspective
and those values people deserve to be
able to vote for that in this election
unless remember the norm is that parties
stand in election candidates yeah but
yeah well you would also say that this
is an unusual election in that it's a
brexit election you like in which leave
remain trumps it wouldn't use advise
people to vote tactically in those seats
to return a Labour MP to ensure that
there's a second referendum why wouldn't
you do that if you want to stop praxis
so so Beth because this election is an
unusual election we have reached an
unprecedented
arrangement through unites remain there
are 60 seats where the not coming so
hunters aggress also labor seats that
either labor held or Tory seats that
held whether labor of the main contender
and you're going to split the vote and
they're going to go they are going to
potentially go to a pro brexit party and
you said that above everything else you
want to stop brexit so why don't you
stand people down in those seats
you can still contest the seats that you
think you have a real chance of winning
off the Conservatives say in the
southwest
I think it's contradictory I entirely
disagree we are standing down in some
seats with other rival parties but not
for a Labour Party whose leader wants to
deliver reg there and for Brewers and a
second referendum but he wants breaks it
yes I actually said what he wants
they're offering a people's vote there's
a better outcome if you were a Mainer
than than Boris Johnson for exit so
totally they're totally letting down
people who want to remain in the
European Union just as they have done
over the last three years just as they
did when nineteen Labour MPs voted for
Boris Johnson's break City no Swinson
though okay let's just let's truly write
down let's take Canterbury I had a look
at it
labour won that seat rosy duffle took
that seat from the Conservatives last
session by a hundred and eighty seven
votes both parties have twenty five
thousand votes apiece
a hundred and eight-seven in between the
Lib Dems in that election four point
five four and a half thousand votes
right if people vote in Lib Dem in
Canterbury and instead of Labour you
split the vote the Tories are through
the middle do you honestly think in
Canterbury that people that want to
remain should vote Lib Dem yeah I think
that it's important that in every
constituency people have the chance to
vote for a party that is absolutely
clearly remain impressive tactical
routing is not new you know it's
something which has existed in election
you know since you're partly because
we've got such an appalling electoral
system and I'm sure in different states
around the country different candidates
in different parties will make different
tactical arguments but it's my job to
make sure that people have the chance to
vote for a party that will absolutely
stand up to remain errs in all
circumstances and that party is the
Liberal Democrats and there are lots of
seats
we're in previous elections it might
have looked close between the
conservatives and labour party what
about that perhaps but the current but
the current situation is entirely too
far as live them supporters in
Canterbury to do of course I am
supporters to vote liberal democrat and
as I said if you have a conservative
read and labour seat turns Tory it's up
to the Labour Party to be the case for
people's labor I'm gonna make that the
risk is that you do become the
handmaiden of brexit lean it could have
actually had an unofficial alliance with
Labour Party you've chosen not I mean
I'd like the split vote let's be clear
you know the unite remain organizers did
approach the Labour Party they said they
weren't interested in any kind of remain
alliance one can only imagine staff just
one interest what doing it through the
press can only imagine Raj did it
unilaterally well I'm not Nigel front
you know you can only imagine that is
because labour aren't a remain party and
they're not interested in alliances
Liberal Democrats have we have
negotiated that with other parties and
indeed you know it stood down in back as
people don't want it grieve and in Brock
Stoffer a know super okay I've got just
one more thing I wanted to ask about
just in terms of the squeeze in the
polling it also seems to be rather a
personal issue for you the polling shows
that the more voters see of you Joe
Swanson I'm afraid to say the less they
like you look I'm standing for what I
believe in I'm setting out my vision for
a brighter future for our country where
we can tackle the climate emergency we
can invest in the mental health crisis
that so many people are facing make sure
our children get the best start and
introduce more free child care because I
believe our country can be better than
what is on offer from Boris Johnson and
Jeremy what do you think's going wrong
I mean we've still got three weeks left
in the election campaign Beth I'm
delighted that sky has set up a debate
on the 20th of November so that I can
take on Boris Johnson and Jeremy Corbyn
let me tell you I'm looking forward to
that and I very much hope that they will
turn up but I just I know it's a bit
uncomfortable but you I mean the polling
suggests that you as an individual are
more unpopular than the actual Party gee
wish you hadn't put that big picture of
you on the bus no I'm absolutely fine
with the bus and I'm looking forward to
taking on Boris Johnson and Jeremy
Corbyn yeah I'm making my pitch I'm
standing up for what I believe in
because I do think our country deserves
better and I'm really worried at the
moment about the path and the direction
that we are on and I'm going to do
everything I can to try to make sure
that we have a better future for my
children for your children for all the
children in our country you know what is
being put forward by Boris Johnson with
his hard brexit by Jeremy Corbyn by
refusing to say where he stands on it
it's just not good enough and I'm
determined to make sure that people have
a genuine choice right thank you very
much thank you